I have a confession to make for whatever
reason I'm probably the only person on
this planet that has not really used
Facebook before but as a few weeks ago
I've become obsessed I'm constantly
checking my profile do I have any new
updates are there any new well-posed
anything like my last status update my
new photo you guys are probably like
Justine what's in it for us how about a
brand new 64 dude iPod touch oh yeah you
know the one that does video photos and
FaceTime calling now I'm not going to
make this too difficult all you have to
do is like my page on Facebook I'll be
choosing someone at random from the
people who have liked my page also feel
free to comment on my wall because I
will periodically be commenting back and
by periodically I mean probably I'll be
on every five seconds checking if you
have any new wall comments now this part
is optional depending upon who actually
wins the iPod if you want I will also
record you a personal video message on
the iPod that you can cherish forever
but maybe you might not want me to do
that so I will let the winner decide
this is the last that you're gonna hear
about this here on youtube so be sure to
go to my page click like and I'll be
updating with the winner there on my
page in the next few weeks thank you
guys so much for being so awesome I look
forward to seeing who wins this and
hopefully recording you a wonderful
video message on your brand-new iPod and
our students on Facebook